abone ol
de
bundan yaklaşık bir buçuk iki ay önce
yine ve eğitim sonrasında bugünkü
konuşma için bir davet aldım topluluğa
konuşma yapmayı çok seviyorum gruptan
birilerinin birkaç kişinin benim
anlattıklarımdan sonra bir şeyleri
değiştirip dönüştürebilme ihtimali beni
çok mutlu ediyor ve heyecanlandırıyor
ve içindeki en büyük motivasyon larından
biri de bu olunca kabul ettim her şey
yolundaydı
bu ta ki iki üç gün önce bugünkü
konuşmanın planını yapmak isteyene kadar
çünkü genelde plana bağlı bir konuşmacı
değilim Ben
spontan akışta konuşuyorum alımla ilgili
konuştuğum için de hiç hazırlık
yapmıyorum şu an konuşuyorum Sorun da
buydu Ben konuştukça konuşuyordum
yaptığım en Aslı'nın İki buçuk üç
saatten bugünün süresi sadece 2/18 kaydı
biraz stres olmuştum Ama yaparım dedim
bu 18 dakika indirmeye çalışırken Biraz
egzersiz yaptım bırakın 18 dakika
ellerde falan Kaldım dedim ki ben en
iyisi tedx konuşmacıları Nasıl
çalışıyorlar iyi yöntemi vardır bunun o
şekliyle çalışayım ona göre plan lıyım
bakmaya başladım
o bakmaz olaydım Çünkü rakamlar söyledi
bu ortalama rakamlardan bahsediyorum
bu metnin toplam uzunluğu 4000 sözcükten
oluşmalı diyordu benim metnim 14000
üstüydü azaltma gerekiyordu dakikada 190
sözcük kullanarak konuşulsun deniyordu
Ben dakikada kaç sözcük kullandığını
bilmiyordum O zamana kadar baktım 65
civarında dayım birazcık çalıştım 85-90
oldu orada hızlı almam gerekiyordu
sahne dekoru onu görsel efekt sunum
kullanın etki gücünü arttırın diyorlardı
bende o da yok tuşu çoklu provalar dan
bahsediyordu 200 prova yapıp buraya
çıkmışlardı konuşmacılar etkili olanlar
benimse zamanım yoktu
ve iyice panik olmaya başladım ve sonra
dedim ki kendi kendime bir saniye Meltem
bugün size anlatacağım konu hayatın
anlamını hayatın anlamını uzaklaşmak
durumunda olduğunu fark ettim ve dedim
ki sakin ol sen etkili konuşma uzman
değilsin sahne sanatçısı da değilsin şık
paylaşmak istediğini anlat ve keyif al
Çünkü biliyordum burada bu durumdan
keyif alacağından ki şu an öyle Evet
kendimi ikna ettim ve burada
karşınızdayım
Ben bugün size hayatın anlamından
bahsedeceğim
bu hikaye söyle başlıyor
o yıllar önce bir gün
de babama hastane yatırmış dönüyordum
Bu hastalığı ciddi değildi
Bu benim için birçok şey hatta her şey
hastalığı öğrendiğim andan itibaren
anlamını yitirmişti
da tam olarak bomboş hissediyordum
o kendi kendine bütün anlamlar nereye
gitti diye mırıldandım
bu nereye gitmişti bütün anlamlar
ve etkili bir giriş oldu değil mi Çünkü
tehlikeli ipuçlarından biri de bu ve
etkili başlangıç yapıyor etki gücü
yüksek bir başlangıç yapmak için böyle
bir konuşmayla girdim Yoksa bu olayların
hiçbir yaşanmadı yani Kendime soruyorum
sıklıkla sorduğu bir sorudur
yaşamın bir anlamı var mı Hayatın Anlamı
ne Meltem senin için hayatın anlamı var
mı diye sorduğumda Çok geçmeden cevap
veririm Evet benim için hayatın bir
anlamı var o an
hayatın anlamının ne olduğunu bilmesem
de önemli olan şudur
Ama şunu farkındayım dır benim hayatımın
bir anlamı vardır Bunu biliyorum dur
bildiğin başka bir şey daha var var ne
zaman benim için hayatın anlamı şudur
desem ve yaptığım şey devam etsem Başka
anlamlar keşfediyorum öyle değildir bir
şey yapmaya başlarsınız devam ederken
Yolda belki başka insanlarla
karşılaşırsınız
farklı duygular hissedersiniz farklı
yollara girersiniz farklı yollar farklı
Barış larla biter
daha sonra bambaşka duygular hissetmeye
başlarsınız ve
sonuçta bambaşka bir anlam oluşmuş olur
başladığımız noktadan çok farklı
bambaşka bir anlam
o zaman önce kabul etmeliyiz
bu hayatın bir anlamı olduğunu kabul
etmeliyiz
Eğer kabul edersek kabul ettiğimiz şey
bulmamız kolaylaşır kabul etmezsek ona
karşı da inanç doğurmayı ve
motivasyonumuz oluşmaz bulmamız da
zorlaşır Bugün size Bu salonda içinde
Sizin için çok önemli bir şeyin olduğu
pembe bir kutu olduğunu söylesem Evet
ben koydum Şu an Bu salonda içinde Sizin
için çok önemli bir şey olan pembe bir
kutu var desem
bu aradığınızda ve bulamadığınız da şunu
yaparsınız ya bir dakika başka yerlerde
bakayım dersiniz yine bulamadığınız da
yok burada bir yerlerde bulacağım bulmak
için başka yöntemler denersiniz ama
zorlarsanız ama pes etmezsiniz
ve motivasyonumuz vardır Çünkü yaşamda
da böyle eğer o kutunun burada olduğunu
bilmezseniz arayıp bulmak için çaba sarf
etmezsiniz et bakarsınız
var ama bulamadığınız da vazgeçersiniz a
Demek ki yokmuş dersiniz
ne demek ki önce kabul edeceğiz
bu bizim için buradaki herkes için
hepimiz için hayatın bir anlamı var
olmalı
son dakikalar geçti
arabada yalnızdım
ve en sevdiğim müziklerden bir iş almaya
başladı
ve o ana kadar Sadece hastalığı
düşünürken bir an Çocukluğum babamla
yaşadıklarımız aklıma geldi
Ben babamla yaşadım o güzel keyifli
anlar
bu arabayı kenara çektim
bu yola sırada da etrafta sadece
tarlalar var dışı öyle gün batımı
denizin maviliği çam ormanları gibi
insanı etkileyen hiç bir manzara yoktu
da tam olarak suçlunun ortasındaydı
sanki
ki Arabadan indim
bu yaslandım arabaya
bu müziği dinledim
ve o gün orada biliyordum
Ben babamla bir geleceğimiz olmayacaktı
artık
da gelecek büyük bir boşluk gibi bazen
karşımızda durur kocaman büyük bir
boşluk gibi
üniversite sınavına hazırlanan ama hangi
bölümde okuyacağım bilmeyen bir öğrenci
gibi de birbirine aşık
ama geleceği olmayan
ayrılacaklarını bilmelerine rağmen hala
birbirlerini sevmeye devam eden iki
insan gibi i gelecek bilinmez büyük bir
boşluk olarak karşımızda durduğunda
içimizde bir anlamsızlık ismi oluşmaya
başlar
yok Kendi kendimize sormaya başlarız
Sen neden yapıyorum ki ne değişecek ki
yaparsam ne fark edecek ki Yapmazsam ne
olacak ki neden çalışıyorum ki gibi bir
çok Soru sormaya başlarız kendimize İşte
bu sorular içimizde oluşmuş anlamsızlık
duygusunu belirtileridir aslında ama
şu şununla belirtisidir artık ip sesimiz
bize bu sorularla geldiğinde şunu
biliyoruz şunu bilmeliyiz
bu sorular bize harekete geç demek bu
sorular bize artık kişiyle değiştir
demek keke Evet
anlamsızlık ise oluşturan soruları
hissettiğinizde bunları iç sesimiz bize
söylediğinde artık harekete geçme zamanı
gelmiştir
da gelecek böyle büyük bir boşluk gibi
karşınızda durduğunda
he he tercih yapmalıyız
var ya boşlukta kaybolup gideceğiz
var ya da geçmişin güvenli alanına geçip
sırtımızı ona yaslayacağım ve ayakta
duracağız oradan bir çalacağız Peki o
geçmişin güvenli olanı nasıl bulacağız
geçmişin güvenli alanı
Bu yaşadığımız
hatırladığımız hatırlarken de bizi
gülümseten keyifli anlar
Allah
hepimize de bir gün ileride ihtiyacımız
olduğunda güç alacağımız geçmişte
keyifli anları var Buna eminim
da bulalım onları bulalım o keyifli
anları ki gelecekte ihtiyacımız
olduğunda oradan güç alabilirim
mi Evet
gelecek büyük bir boşluk gibi karşınızda
durduğunda
ve ona karşı tavır almamız gerektiğini
biliyoruz Artık
o Çünkü biz seçim yaptık queue Bu seçim
bizi bir yola götürecek pek Evet biz
seçim yapmalıyız
de bu seçim
bu özgür bir seçim olmalı o özgür seçim
bizi harekete geçirecek şey fakat bu
seçimi yaparken
bazen aklımız bize yol göstermeye
olabilir
İyi o zaman kalbinizin sesini
dinlemeliyiz Çünkü bizi yola götürecek
olan şey bizi istediğiniz yaptıracak
olan şey aslında Kalbimizin sesidir
bu çünkü
bu kalbim bildiği ama mantığı bilmediği
bazı şeyler vardır
mi Evet geçmiş anılarımıza yaslana
bildiğiniz de ayaktayız bir artık
geleceğin boşluğunda kaybolmamış hızdır
şimdiki zaman dilimi içerisinde
kendinizi güçlü hissediyoruz dur
var ama bu anı yaşamak Carpe Diem falan
değil Sakın karıştırmayın bu içinde
bulunduğu zaman diliminde kendi yaşamına
kendi hayatına tam olarak her şeyiyle
sahip çıkmak ya da sahip çıkabilme
cesareti göstermektir Bu bir tavır
almaktır tavır almak öyle kenara geçip
yaşanacak olanları beklemek değil tavır
almak öyle günlerin geçmesini beklemek
değildir bir tavır almak biraz önce
söylediğim gibi
bir seçim yaparak harekete geçmektir
Eğer
siz de bugün
ve o günkü Meltem gibi
bu boş bir geleceğe bakıyor
olabilirsiniz
bu ne yapacağınızı bilmiyor Onun
belirsizliğinde
var ya da
geleceği olmayan bir aşkın Ayrılık
öncesinde sini
bu işte o zaman şunu biliyoruz Artık
ve bu duygumuz bizde anlamsızlık iste
oluşturan Duygu mu bir tavır almamız
gerektiriyor yaşama karşı bir tavır
almalıyız bunun için önce kabul
etmeliyiz hayatın bir anlamı var
bu sonra
o geçmişte yaşadıklarımızı yaşamadık
larımızı
yapamadıklarımızı eleştirel ya da onları
değersizleştiren bir bakışla değil o
yaşadıklarımızın Bizi bugüne getirdiğini
farkındalığı yla
geçmişte yaşadıklarımızdan güç almalıyız
ve oraya yazsam malıyız bunu
yapabildiğimiz de artık ok Atik ne
olduğu bilinmeyen stresli alandan
çıkmışız dır buradayız dır denge
değildir ve daha sağlıklı karar
verebilecek durumdayız dır Evet burada
daha sağlıklı kararlar verebiliriz ve en
son bize o kararı verecek olan şeyin
mantığımız değil bu Kalbimiz olduğunu
bilmeliyiz
mi Evet
ama ben o gün orada kalbimin sesini
dinleyerek
en yeni bir anlam yeni bir üst anlam
oluşturdum bugün anlattığım hikayede
size
babamın ölümüyle
Aslında çok ciddi bir boşluğa düştüğünü
ve bu ciddi boşluktan onunla olan
anılarıma sığınarak oradan güç olarak
gelecekte kaybı olmadığını ve
oluşturduğum yeni anlamda nasıl ayakta
durabildiği paylaşmak istedim
mi Evet benim bulduğum anlam insanlara
yardım etmek olmuştu ama burada belki Bu
salonda benimle aynı anlamı bulanlar var
bu belki hepimizin anlamı birbirinden
çok farklı çünkü anlam birileri için aşk
Annem birileri için
statüsü para güç anlam birileri için bir
çocuk belki
mi Evet ben insanlara
o kendi anlamlarını bulmak için yardım
etmeye karar vermiştim benim kalbimin
bana söylediği buydu
kalbinin bildiği buydu bu ve o günkü
meltemin o gün oluşturduğu anlam yaşamın
anlamı buydu
bu ve bilmenizi isterim
Ben bugün size babamın hastalığı ile
ilgili anlattığım var
bu hırsız yol kenarı
o Çiftliğin ortasında kalmam
Ben babamla olan anılarımız
bu hastalığa ve Onu kaybetmiş olmam
ama hepsi gerçek
Çok teşekkür ederim
abone ol